this morning 14 fraternities at San
Diego State University are under
suspension after the death of a freshman
19 year old Dylan Hernandez died after a
fraternity party last week the school is
investigating and says it's uncovered
evidence that a fraternity may have been
engaged in possible misconduct Jamie
yuccas is following this story from Los
Angeles Jamie what more do we know about
the circumstances surrounding the
students death well this is what we're
learning Anthony Friends of Dylan
Hernandez call him an outgoing and
light-hearted person who had so much
love to give
university officials have not released
the cause of death so we don't know
whether alcohol or hazing was involved
but students have had long-standing
concerns about Greek life on campus my
heart goes out to him and strands his
family
tributes are pouring in for Dylan
Hernandez the San Diego State University
undergrad who died last Friday after
being rushed to a hospital the day
before and I think that everyone would
agree it's just a well around really
good person Hernandez was in his dorm
room when he fell off his bunk bed and
hit his head the medical examiner says
his roommate found him unconscious
without a pulse several students say
Hernandez had been drinking heavily at a
fraternity party you could tell they
kick over partied like more than like
usual so Evan was like whoa like just
make sure he was okay
14 fraternities affiliated with the
interpreter natee Council have been
suspended
SDSU did not reveal the name of the frat
that hosted the party Hernandez attended
Hernandez was pledging to one of those
newly suspended fraternities Phi Gamma
Delta according to the school's student
newspaper the chapter was placed on
probation in 2017 after being quote
found in violation of regulations
pertaining to alcohol and off campus
fraternity events like the party culture
like they just kind of get used to it
and that's
they don't you don't think it was like
they're having a good time
SDSU students say alcohol violations
stretch across campus
they hope the suspension of the
fourteenth eternities leads to the
university taking action on the issue
this has been a problem for a while
we've seen alcohol abuse on this campus
so hopefully this will create a
healthier environment for the school the
San Diego Police Department is not yet
involved in the case it would only take
over if Hernandez's death is ruled a
homicide by the Medical Examiner's
Office
meanwhile friends of the Hernandez
family have put up a GoFundMe page to
raise money to quote helped to create
memorials for family and friends as a
way to grieve Tony a very sad story our
in Jaime thank you very much